une nouvelle vague doit être
collectivement anticipées le conseil
scientifique qui guide le gouvernement
alerte sur la propagation du variant
delta en france pour faire barrage au
virus
il avance de nouvelles mesures anti go
vide l'exécutif suivra-t-il ses
recommandations emmanuel macron
s'adressera
dire à 20 heures
[Musique]
des troupes vont être envoyés pour
reprendre le poste frontière d'islam
callas en afghanistan principal point de
passage avec les rangs et des sous
contrôle des talibans depuis hier les
insurgés qui affirment à contrôler
désormais 85% du territoire alors que le
retrait des soldats américains est en
cours il sera achevé d'ici au 31 août
[Musique]
haïti un appel à l'aide militaire des
états unis de l'onu
trois jours après l'assassinât du
président joao née louise les autorités
du pays demande l'envoi de troupes and
co des sites stratégiques ne soit saboté
une aide sécuritaire et en matière d'
enquête aussi pour faire notamment la
lumière sur les raisons de cet acte et
sur l'identité de ses commanditaires
[Musique]
bonsoir et bienvenue si vous nous
rejoignez sur rt france vaccination
obligatoire des soignants free mesures
de restriction localiser c'est ce que
recommande le conseil scientifique au
moment où le variant delta gagne du
terrain
60 % plus contagieux que les souches
précédentes il représente un cas sur
deux des contaminations en france et
pourrait devenir majoritaires ce week
end
le conseil scientifique réclame un tour
de vis
emmanuel macron prendra la parole lundi
soir le chef de l'état suivra-t-il les
conseils de l'instance cela n'a pas
toujours été le cas ces derniers mois
solène gaudin 11 mars 2020 olivier véran
alors fraîchement nommé ministre de la
santé créé le conseil scientifique au
vide 19 son rôle épauler le gouvernement
dans ses décisions face à l'épidémie
son président devient alors omniprésent
jean françois delfraissy en réunion
interministérielle delfraissy face à la
presse delfraissy au sénat l'immunologue
est partout et c'est sur les
recommandations du conseil scientifique
que le président de la république prend
la décision d'un confinement strict à
partir du 17 mars 2020 l'institution et
l'exécutif main dans la main face à
l'épidémie
une idylle qui sera de courte durée
première brouille était 2020 le
gouvernement choisit d'ignorer les
alertes du conseil scientifique sur un
déconfinement trop précoce puis les
rapports se tendent un peu plus au début
de l'année 2000 21
emmanuel macron décide de ne pas re
confinée après les fêtes de fin d'année
face à la troisième vague allant contre
les préconisations du conseil un
confinement précoce permet de gagner du
temps à un moment critique
la reprise de la circulation épidémique
à l'issue du confinement aura lieu dans
un contexte où vaccination et nouveaux
traitements seront davantage disponibles
et pourront réduire l'impact de la
circulation du virus sur le système de
santé un avis
alarmiste selon l'exécutif il est quand
même incroyable delfraissy
il préconise l'auto confinement des
personnes âgées mais dans ce cas qu'il
se l'appliquent à lui même
que fait-il sur les plateaux télé les
chiffres lui donnent raison
le confinement c'eût été la solution de
facilité
la mesure de confort tels frais s'y voit
sa vente des premières heures de
l'épidémie passé sous silence par un
exécutif qui cherche à mettre de la
distance avec les médecins alarmiste
sans doute pour gagner l'adhésion du
public
en avril dernier c'est le coup de grâce
du côté du pouvoir politique
on se passera du conseil scientifique
pour élaborer le calendrier de
déconfinement 2 mai à juin 2021
encore une fois jugée prématurée par les
sages dans une publication sortie dans
la plus grande discrétion
mais face à la quatrième vague de
coronavirus qui s'amorce en ce moment
l'institution et l'exécutif pourrait
renouer de bons rapports sur un sujet la
vaccination obligatoire des soignants
dans un avis rendu public ce vendredi le
conseil scientifique se dit favorable à
cette mesure alors que le gouvernement
vient de mener cette semaine une série
de concertations emmanuel macron
s'adressera aux français ce lundi à 20
heures et pourrait bien annoncer sa
décision sur la vaccination des
soignants une allocution qui pourrait
bien apaisé les relations avec le
conseil scientifique
à moins de trois mois de la fin de sa
mission qui doit s'achever le 30
septembre
la vaccination en impératif éthique pour
l'académie de médecine l'institution se
déclare en faveur de son obligation dé
12 ans c'est la huitième fois depuis le
début de la pandémie qu'elle prend ainsi
position concernant l'ensemble de la
population âgée de 12 ans et plus
l'obligation vaccinale contre la copie
de 19 constitue la seule option réaliste
en termes de responsabilisation
personnelle et d'engagement solidaire
permettant de préserver sa santé
celle des autres est de parvenir à
l'immunité collective l'obligation
s'impose quand une vaccination efficace
et bien toléré peut maîtriser une
infection sévères potentiellement
mortels et incontrôlable par tout autre
moyen
mais rendre la vaccination obligatoire
risquerait de stigmatiser les soignants
selon patrick bourguignon secrétaire
fédérale 2
j'étais santé mettre une obligation
c'est au contraire aussi baptisé c'est
au contraire à le voir mettre à l'écart
et c'est au contraire vouloir dire d'un
côté qui a des bons soignants et
mourinho la vraie question qui se pose
c'est de quelle façon est ce qu'on met
en situation les professionnels que nous
sommes d'avoir suffisamment d'effectifs
ou lorsque nous sommes malades ne
pouvoir ne pas aller au travail tout
simplement parce que nous savons que
nous serons à remplacer lorsque les
symptômes c'est ne pas aller au travail
comme ça a été le cas et ça a été imposé
une personne est lors de la phase i du
passage de la deuxième et la troisième
vague les personnels qui avait les
symptômes ont les imposer à venir au
travail donc maintenant imposer à
l'inversé la vaccination on est sûr sur
des réflexions et surtout ceux des des
mouvements politiques sont des
mouvements politiques qui rendent pas
forcément crédible le discours ce
gouvernement donc nous on pense que oui
la vaccination est indispensable et très
clairement indispensable maintenant la
mise en oeuvre cette vaccination ne doit
pas passer par une contrainte et qui
aboutira à des sanctions
il doit passer par un élément cutanée
moins d'arriver à convaincre malgré
l'inquiétude liée aux variants deltell
déconfinement se poursuit avec la
réouverture hier des discothèques après
plus de quinze mois de fermeture
condition sinequanone pour les fêtards
être muni d'un passe sanitaire
reportages en banlieue parisienne de
jordi de maurice medias keffieh grain de
sel et met sur pause depuis la mi mars
2020 la fête reprend ses droits dans les
boîtes de nuit française depuis ce
vendredi soir mais pour pouvoir investir
la piste de danse
il faut se plier aux contraintes du pass
sanitaire test qu'ovide de moins de 48
heures
arco vaccinale complété depuis au moins
deux semaines ou attestation de guérison
constitue le sésame indispensable pour
passer les portes des établissements
nocturnes des obstacles qui font
craindre aux professionnels du secteur
une reprise en demi teinte content de
réouvrir parce que vous avez tellement
longtemps donc effectivement content de
réouvrir mais la foi j'appréhende un
petit peu parce que je ne sais pas
comment des gens les gens vont réagir
comment ça va se passer est ce que va
avoir les mêmes influences qu'avant je
ne pense pas mais c'est vraiment ou kent
est en fonction sur le cac en prenant
les dispositions
j'ai l'impression que les gens
on était ont été emballés par la
réouverture notamment de lempire club
ils ont ils ont ils ont répondu présent
après ce qu'ils vont faire l'effort
encore une fois de faire un test pcr ou
antigénique pour aller en discothèque ça
c'est vraiment une autre problématique à
l' empire discothèque de banlieue
parisienne
un dispositif de test antigénique est
installé par les gérants pour permettre
aux clients de présenter une preuve
valide à l'entrée on a eu des patients
qui se plaignait un peu mais après
franchement fin de mon point de vue je
trouve ça un peu abusé c'est vrai que ça
reste quand même très rapide on a une
prise en charge qui dure 10 minutes donc
franchement pour havret pouvoir aller
s'amuser en boîte de nuit sachant qu'on
sort d'une période de co vide donc en
soit franchement je trouve ça largement
satisfaisant je vaccine et j'ai mon qr
codes avec moi
je pense que c'est bien parce que il
faut se protéger donc je pense que c'est
bien de filtrer les entrées que je vais
essayer de garder la distance pour
éviter d'avoir le masque avec la chaleur
c'est un peu compliqué le mas on essaie
de garder la distance
moi je suis très contente de refaire la
fête ça faisait longtemps et ça m'avait
archi manquait un retour sur la scène
pour les artistes également malgré une
certaine appréhension la chanteuse
martiniquaise maureen ne cachait pas son
enthousiasme à l'idée de se produire à
nouveau en boîte de nuit
clairement quand j'ai vu les conditions
je me suis si pur et c'est chaud est-ce
que tu montes viendra mais bon les gens
sont assez déterminée j'ai envie de dire
après deux ans et demi
resté confiné
avec certaine mobilité donc ouais c'est
assez compliqué c'est vrai mais pour la
sécurité de tous c'est préférable
malheureusement et mais entre la
complexité liée aux contraintes
sanitaires et les difficultés
financières bon nombre de boîtes de nuit
ont décidé de rester portes closes en ce
9 juillet de réouverture et en catalan
discothèques ont refermé chez elle avait
pu rouvrir il ya seulement deux semaines
décision prise par les autorités qui en
raison d'une flambée épidémique
principalement chez les jeunes hier soir
à barcelone des dizaines d'entre eux se
sont rassemblés dans la rue la police
est intervenue pour disperser la foule
on part maintenant en tunisie sous la
situation sanitaire est catastrophique
le pays enregistre des records de
contamination les hôpitaux sont saturés
et victimes collatérales de cette
nouvelle vague le tourisme un nouveau
coup dur pour les professionnels du
secteur qui tente tant bien que mal de
sauver la saison estivale reportage de
bassam chebbi et verra nasri une plage
de sable blanc vidé de ses vacanciers
des restaurants fermés et des routes
quasi déserte
c'est le décor imposé par un confinement
strict déclaré sur l'ensemble du
gouvernorat
face à la recrudescence des cas de
contamination et la découverte du
variant indien dans la région le comité
régional de lutte contre les
catastrophes naturelles à sousse a
décrété un confinement total du 4 au 11
juillet un coup dur qui aurait pu
plomber le moral des professionnels du
tourisme
bien décidé à sauver leur saison si le
cas de mr ferchichi à la tête du marhaba
palace de kantaoui
le jeune directeur a décidé de tout
miser sur la sécurité
de quoi rassurer sa clientèle
essentiellement étrangère mise en place
de protocoles sanitaires strict respect
des distances iations sociale ou encore
allègement de sa capacité d'accueil dans
cet établissement
l'ensemble du personnel est vaccinée
objectif permettre à ses résidents de
profiter de leurs vacances en toute
sécurité
actuellement notre hôtel à une
occupation de 50
portant nous sommes en conformité même
avec le protocole sanitaire qui exige un
hôtel de ne pas dépasser les 50% de
l'occupation pour bien maîtriser la
situation je n'ai pas un sentiment de
peur v que toujours j'ai un esprit de
positivité j'ai confiance dans les
mesures qui sont prises par le ministère
de santé au par le ministère de tourisme
qui sont randonnée en train de donner de
bons signes pour
nos clients ainsi que nos partenaires
tour à tour opérateur il a prévenu que
jusqu'à ce jour on a des presque 50% de
l'occupation on a presque des
réservations pour le mois de la fin de
mois de juillet même d'août et de
septembre donc se confirme que que
soient les tour opérateurs ou les
potentiels clients ont confiance à la
destination malgré la situation
sanitaire inquiétante dans le pays
beaucoup de ces clients n'ont pas hésité
à maintenir leurs réservations
roger pas eu peur j'ai passé les tests
pcr on a été vaccinées en france pas de
souci à l'aéroport iv les règles
sanitaires même à l'hôtel gel masque
n'ont pas de soucis on est vacciné nous
totalement deux fois deux injections
donc on a à mon sens pas plus de risques
que de rester en france qu'elles soient
métropolitaine ou autre forcément que ça
amène des contraintes on peut pas
visiter aussi bien les villes aux
alentours ou même le pays en entier mais
bon voilà ici on est quand même dans un
cadre privilégié
on a tout à disposition pour passer une
bonne journée on n'a pas hésité un
instant à venir d'autant plus qu'on est
vaccinée de plus nous n'avons pas eu
d'informations concernant cette
recrudescence de cas de coded en tunisie
la situation ne nous inquiètent pas plus
que ça comme je vous ai dit nous sommes
vaccinés et on a observé qu ici le
protocole sanitaire est respecté et
appliqué comme mr ferchichi ils sont
nombreux à travers tout le pays à s'être
adapté rapidement au contexte épidémique
est aux restrictions gouvernementales
même son de cloche du côté de l'office
national du tourisme tunisien
pour le directeur central de la
promotion touristique l'enjeu est de
taille
que ce soit pour les étrangers ou les
locaux sauver les meubles et la mission
que s'est fixée le ministère du tourisme
et l'office national du tourisme en
partenariat avec les acteurs du secteur
nous de notre côté nous vivons elle nous
suivant niveau l'évolution de la
situation
chez nous il faut qu'il y est
une disposition au niveau international
pour les vacanciers les touristes de
partir suivant les conditions qui sont
les leurs sur les marchés émetteurs
il faut qu'il y ait une disposition de
notre part sur en tunisie pour pouvoir
recevoir de la clientèle nous avons ce
protocole de protocole sanitaire qui a
été mise en place depuis mars ou avril
2001 il est régulièrement mis à jour
mais malheureusement la rhdp d'essence
de la pandémie a fait en sorte que nous
sommes malheureusement touché de plein
fouet
après une saison estivale chaotique l'an
passé les tunisiens espère ne pas
revivre un tel scénario cette année
malgré un taux de contamination à la
hausse une campagne vaccinale qui
fonctionnent au ralenti et des
gouvernorats qui se confient les uns
après les autres les professionnels du
tourisme veulent y croire
une question de survie dans ce pays où
10% des actifs dits du tourisme a logé
vers donne son feu vert à l'accord sur
la taxation des multinationales réunis à
venise a depuis hier les ministres des
finances des 20 pays les plus riches du
monde approuve donc cette réforme qui
prévoit de mettre fin aux paradis
fiscaux en instaurant un impôt mondial
d'au moins 15% sur les bénéfices une
architecture fiscale international plus
stable et plus équitable selon les
termes employés
la réforme a été menée sous l'égide de
l'osce et des oeufs sont 31 de ses 139
membres l'ont approuvé les ministres des
finances ont adressé un appel aux pays
récalcitrants pour qu'ils rallient cet
accord
les autorités afghanes comptent bien
reprendre le plus important est
principal poste frontière avec l'iran le
porte parole du gouverneur de la
province d'herat dans l'ouest du pays a
déclaré dans la journée que les troupes
allaient être envoyés pour reprendre ce
poste frontière d'islam cas là il est
tombé hier aux mains des talibans qui
affirment contrôler aujourd'hui et 85%
du territoire afghan
le chef du pentagone appelle à une
pression internationale pour un accord
entre kaboul et les insurgés
la situation sécuritaire en afghanistan
ne fait que renforcer la pression
internationale en faveur d'un règlement
politique négocié pour mettre fin à ce
conflit est donnée au peuple afghan le
gouvernement qu'il souhaitait qu'il
mérite
le monde entier peut aider en
poursuivant cette pression et
l'offensive des talibans se poursuit
alors que le retrait des troupes
américaines s'accélère donc quelques
semaines l'armée afghane se retrouvera
seul face aux insurgés
la population est inquiète j'ai dû
quitter mes proches pour fuir vers
kaboul
la situation n'était pas bonne ils se
battent entre eux quant aux civils pris
au milieu il souffre énormément et sont
dans la misère
il retirera ses troupes d'afghanistan
quelle que soit la situation
on peut en déduire que l'avenir de
l'afghanistan n'est pas si important
pour les états unis et le revers à
présent de david rigoulet roze rédacteur
en chef de la revue aux rayons
stratégiques
les talibans ont annoncé qu'ils
contrôlaient 85% du territoire d'ores et
déjà bon il faut se méfier des chiffres
parce que il ya une logique auto enfin
on va dire de prophétie auto
réalisatrice de la part des talibans et
une logique de propagande très efficace
d'ailleurs qui est alimenté à la fois
par des vidéos de reddition de soldats
de l'armée nationale afghane
objectivement de prise de contrôle des
des points de passage frontaliers avec
les divers pays limitrophes de
l'aghanistan donc il ya une pression a
compté stablement très forte un des
talibans qui qui suscite des
interrogations qui était attendu par le
retrait américain qui sera achevé fin
août
tel que l'a établi le président joe
biden dont en tout cas il ya
effectivement en termes de communication
une stratégie très élaborés finalement
des talibans qu'on a tendance à
sous-estimer très élaborée qui leur
permet d'avancer leurs pions y compris
par rapport à la population un terrain
en haïti
le commando armé qui a abattu le
président joël moïse a été identifié
chez on ignore en revanche pour
l'instant les raisons cet assassinat et
l'identité de ses commanditaires
les autorités du pays un appel à aux
américains et à l'onu aujourd'hui pour
les aider dans l'enquêté a assuré aussi
la sécurité de certains lieux
stratégiques
maxime a bola beaucoup de questions
beaucoup d'agitation mais très peu de
réponses dans la nuit de mardi à
mercredi le président haïtien jouvenel
moïse a été assassiné à son domicile
une opération menée par un commando de
28 assaillants 26 colombien et deux
américains d'origine haïtienne dont les
motivations restent pour le moment
inconnues face à cette incompréhension
haïti se tourner vers la colombie est ce
ce que nous voulons en ce moment c'est
la vérité la colombie est très solide en
matière d' enquête c'est un pays bien
préparé dans ce domaine ce que nous
voulons c'est la vérité c'était moins le
cas des malades
nous devons travailler dans l'unité
nous devons coopérer dans l'unité pour
que notre peuple ne souffre pas de ces
actes barbares
nesta pas des siennes à des chausse des
sauces c'est de cela qu'il s'agit
mendes à cette date une enquête c'est
que bogota mènent conjointement avec le
gouvernement haïtien
nous avons les premiers détails sur les
voyages que certains d'entre eux ont
fait les dates d'où ils sont partis
quel type
compagnies aériennes ces informations
sont partagées non seulement avec le
bureau central d'interpol en haïti mais
aussi avec la république dominicaine car
les personnes liées à l'incident ont
utilisé comme port d'arrivée la
république dominicaine pour se rendre en
territoire haïtien
d'après bogota 17 des 26 colombiens ont
appartenu à l'armée nationale
parmi ces suspects onze ont été arrêtés
ce vendredi dont le complexe de
l'ambassade de taïwan à port au prince
mais l' enquête semble loin d'être
terminée dans un pays en proie à
l'instabilité et pour éviter que des
infrastructures vitales soit visé pour
créer la confusion
les autorités haïtiennes ont demandé
l'envoi de troupes armées de l'onu et
des états unis
les etats unis restent engagés en
consultation étroite avec nos
partenaires haïtiens et internationaux
pour soutenir le peuple haïtien
en réponse à la demande d'assistance en
matière de sécurité aidant quête
formulée par le gouvernement haïtien
nous allons envoyer des responsables du
fbi et de la sécurité intérieure à
port-au-prince aussi vite que possible
pour évaluer la situation et déterminer
comment nous pouvons apporter notre aide
après l'assassinât de son président en
haïti avait plongé dans le chaos durant
plusieurs jours mais depuis ce vendredi
la tension semble redescendu à port au
prince pourtant l'incompréhension reste
encore palpable et les suspicions
grandissent autour de la police chargée
de la sécurité du président certains
hauts responsables ont été convoqués
devant la justice pour savoir comment
dans cet assaut meurtrier de jouvenel
moïse aucun policier n'a été tué
7 est il ya 36 ans le 10 juillet 1985
deux bondés ventre le rainbow warrior le
chalutier greenpeace a amarré dans le
port d'auckland pour protester contre
les essais nucléaires
une personne est tuée commandité par le
gouvernement français le sabotage devenu
un attentat en train alors un scandale
politique
retour sur cet événement qui a entaché
le mandat de françois mitterrand avec
mode à mona à mode et l'art le 10
juillet 1985 dans le port d'auckland en
nouvelle-zélande deux bombes explosent
sur le rainbow warrior un chalutier
affrété par greenpeace pour se rendre en
polynésie
et empêcher les essais nucléaires
français l'opération se révélera être
commandité par l'état français
les bombes ont été posées par les
services secrets français et ont causé
la mort du photographe de greenpeace
fernando pereira le 12 juillet 1985 la
police néo zélandaise mais l enquête et
interpelle les faux époux dessus range
qui sont en réalité le commandant alain
mafart et la capitaine dominique prieur
deux agents de la dgse identifiées comme
les auteurs de l'attaqué avec trois
nageurs de combat
l'un des membres du commando gerra royal
ancien agent de la dgse n'est autre que
le frère de l'ex ministre de l'écologie
ségolène royal d'après pierre lacoste ex
patron de la dgse
ce sont bel et bien les services secrets
français qui ont fait couler le navire
sur ordre du gouvernement
avec l'autorisation explicite du
président de la république de l'époque
le socialiste françois mitterrand dans
son rapport confidentiel d'avril 1986
l'amiral lacoste raconte son entretien
avec françois mitterrand
il confirme qu'il n'aurait jamais agi
sans l'autorisation personnel du
président de la république
j'ai demandé au président s'il
m'autorisait à mettre en oeuvre le
projet de neutralisation que j'avais
étudié à la demande de monsieur hernu il
m'a donné son accord en manifestant
l'importance qu'il attachait aux essais
nucléaires je ne suis pas alors rentré
dans un plus grand détail du projet
l'autorisation était suffisamment
explicite avec les révélations de
l'implication de l'état français la
sphère du rainbow warrior devient pas un
scandale politique pour le président
françois mitterrand est le premier
ministre laurent fabius
le gouvernement veut éteindre l'incendié
coûte que coûte le ministre de la
défense charles hernu et sert de fusible
et démissionne dans une déclaration à
l'elysée
laurent fabius reconnaît l'implication
de la france le 22 septembre 1985
le nouveau ministre de la défense vient
de m'informer des premières conclusions
de l'enquêté menée sur la sphère du web
beaux arts your j'ai tenu à vous les
faire connaître immédiatement ses
conclusions permettent de cerner la
vérité ce sont des agents de la dgse qui
ont coulé ce bateau ils ont agi sur
ordre après cet aveu l'indignation est
international la sphère fait les gros
titres des médias étrangers
on en parle comme d'un attentat commis
par un pays démocratique contre une
organisation écologiste non violente
l affaire rainbow warrior aura de
lourdes conséquences sur les relations
diplomatiques franco néo zélandaise est
le 22 novembre 1985 les faux époux tu
ranges sont condamnés à 10 ans de
réclusion criminelle en 2015 trente ans
après ce scandale le colonel jean-luc
hyster le nageur de combat de la dgse
qui a posé la charge explosive sur le
chalutier présente ses excuses
trente ans après les événements avec les
passions qui se sont apaisées aussi le
recul que j'ai par rapport à ma vie
professionnelle j'ai pensé que c'était
une occasion pour moi d'exprimer à la
fois mais profond regret mes excuses
j'ai la mort d'un innocent sur la
conscience et ça pèse le capitaine du
rainbow warrior accepte les excuses mais
reste amer j'accepte ses excuses je les
pense sincère j'espère qu'elles lui
permettront de mieux dormir et de vivre
sa vie mais cela n'enlève rien au fait
que lui et ses amis
le président françois mitterrand et tout
ce qui faisait partie de cette équipe
qui ont préparé et mener cette opération
sont des meurtriers
et cela doit être dit en 1987 la france
présente des excuses officielles et
versé 8 millions de dollars d'indemnités
à greenpeace
et cette affaire de moeurs en symbole
cuisant des opérations secrètes menées
par françois mitterrand pendant son
mandat
les essais nucléaires cesse en 1996 soit
onze ans après l' attaque et l'épave du
rainbow warrior repose toujours au large
d'auckland
et on termine ce journal avec notre
rubrique rt sur le web sélection
d'articles à retrouver sur tesfran ce
point tv la hongrie au coeur de fortes
tensions pendant l'euro de football uefa
vient de sanctionner l'équipe nationale
a' l'évoquent un comportement
discriminatoire de ses supporters des
cris racistes auraient été lancées
depuis leurs tribunes lors du match face
à l'équipe de france une décision qui a
provoqué la colère du gouvernement
hongrois qui juge d'instance pathétique
et lâche
un employé es tu es chien autre très
grièvement blessé par arme blanche dans
un magasin de téléphonie de cinéma
l'auteur des faits un homme de 62 ans a
été interpellé l'individu a été maîtrisé
par un policier et un agent
pénitentiaire tous deux hors service à
l'origine de son geste en différend
commercial selon les premiers éléments
de l'enquète au royaume uni se
dirige-t-on vers un blocage des visas
pour les pays qui refusent de prendre en
charge leurs demandeurs d'asile c'est en
tout cas ce qu'envisage le gouvernement
britannique avec un nouveau projet de
loi
par ailleurs les demandeurs d'asile
arrivés illégalement n'auraient plus les
mêmes droits que ceux entrés légalement
des articles à retrouver dans leur
intégralité sur notre site internet
rp france font tv et c'est la fin de
cette édition merci de l'avoir suivi
prochain journal dans une trentaine de
minutes à 21h à tout à l'heure
[Musique]
on
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]